so here's my first question for you very
very simple question what makes you
human me both of you you both have to
answer what makes you human oh and one
word you get one word humor
humor emotion okay um to confirm you're
both human I'm going to need you to
confirm which of these boxes have a
traffic
one I think uh I think I I can do that
too now okay okay all right well Sam you
were actually here nine years ago at our
first tech live and I actually want to
roll the clip of what you said okay
certainly the the fear with with AI or
machine intelligence in general is that
it replaces drivers or doctors or
whatever um
but the optimistic view on this and
certainly what backs up what we're
seeing is that computers and humans are
very good at very different things so a
computer doctor will outc crunch the
numbers and do a better job than a human
on looking at a massive amount of data
and saying this but on cases that
require judgment or creativity or
empathy we are nowhere near any computer
system that is any good at
this okay does 2023 say partially right
and partially wrong okay could have been
worse could have been worse um what's
your outlook
now
people I think the prevailing wisdom
back then was that AI was going to um
do the kind of like robotic jobs really
well first so would have been a great
robotic surgeon something like that um
and then maybe eventually it was going
to do the the sort of like higher
judgment tasks uh and then you know then
it would kind of do the empathy and then
maybe never it was going to be like a
really great creative thinker and
creativity has been in some sense and at
this point the definition of the word
creativity is Up For Debate but
creativity in some sense has been easier
for AI than people people thought you
can you know see Dolly 3 generate these
like amazing images um or write these
creative stories with gb4 or whatever um
so that part of the answer maybe was not
perfect uh and GP I I certainly would
not have predicted GPT 4 nine years ago
um quite how it turned out but a lot of
the other parts about people still
really want a human doctor uh that's
definitely very
true and I want to quickly shift to AGI
what is Agi MF you could just Define it
for everybody in the
audience I will say it's a system that
can generalize across many domains that
you know would be equivalent to human
work um they would produce a lot of uh
productivity and economic value and but
you know we're talking about one system
that can generalize across a lot of
digital domains of human work and Sam
why is Agi the
goal the the two things that I think
will matter most over the next decade or
few decades um to improving The Human
Condition the most giving us sort of
just more of what we want our uh
abundant and inexpensive intelligence um
the more powerful the more General the
smarter the better uh I think that is
Agi and then and then abundant and cheap
energy and if we can get these two
things done in the world then uh it's
almost like difficult to imagine how
much else we could do uh we're big
Believers that you give people better
tools and they do things that astonish
you and I think AGI will be uh the best
tool Humanity has yet created uh with it
we will be able to solve all sorts of
problems we'll be able to express
ourselves in new creative ways we'll
make just incredible things um for each
other for ourselves for the world for
for kind of this unfolding human story
uh and you know it's new and anything
new comes with change and changes uh not
always all easy um but I think this will
be just absolutely tremendous upside
and gonna you know we're gonna nine more
years if you're nice enough to invite me
back you'll roll this question and
people will say like how could we have
thought we didn't want this like how I
guess two parts to that my next question
when will it be here and how will we
know it's here for me or from you well
either one of you I mean you can both
predict how long and we'll call you in
10 years and we'll tell you you're wrong
less than less than that I mean yeah I
yeah probably in the next decade but I
would say it's a bit tricky because we
you know when will it be here right and
I just kind of give you a definition but
then often we talk about intelligence
and you know how intelligent is it or
whether it's conscious and sentient and
all of these terms and you know no
they're not quite right because they
sort of Define our our own intelligence
and we're building something slightly
different and you can kind of see how
the definition of intelligence evolves
from you know machines that were really
great at chess and alago and now the GPT
series and then what's next but it
continues to evolve and it pushes what
how we Define
intelligence we we we kind of Define ai
as like the thing we don't have quite
yet so we've moved I mean there were a
lot of people who would have 10 years
ago said art if you could make something
like GPT 4 GPT 5 maybe that would have
been an AI and and now people are like
well you know it's like a nice little
chat bot or whatever and I think that's
wonderful I think it's great that the
goal posts keep getting moved it makes
us work harder um but I think we're
getting close enough to whatever that
AGI threshold is going to be that we no
longer get to handwave at it and the
definition is going to matter so less
than a decade for some
definition
okay all right the go poost is move
moving um Sam you've used the word um
and and previously when describing AGI
the term median human can you explain
what that is
um I I think there are experts in areas
that are going to be better than AI
systems for a long period of time um and
so like you know you could come to like
some area where I'm like really an
expert at some task and I I'll be like
all right you know GPT 4 is doing a
horrible job there GPT 5 six whatever
doing a horrible job there but you can
come to other tasks where I'm okay but
certainly not an expert I'm kind of like
maybe like an average of what different
people in the world could do at
something and for that uh then I might
look at and say oh this is actually
doing pretty well so what we mean by
that is that the in any given area
expert humans May uh like experts in any
area can like just do extraordinary
things and that may take us a a while to
be able to do with these these systems
but for kind of the more average case
performance so you know me doing
something that I'm like not very good at
anyway maybe our future versions can
help me with that a lot so am I a median
human uh at some tasks I'm sure and it's
some clearly at this you're a very
expert human and no GPT is taking your
job anytime soon okay okay that makes me
feel that makes me feel a little better
uh mea how's that gbt 5
going um we're not there yet but it's
kind of need to know basis I'll let you
know that's such a diplomatic answer I'm
gonna make mirror do all of these I
would have no I would have just said oh
yeah here's what's happening that's
great we're not sending who paired these
two who paired whose idea was this um
you're working on it you're training it
it we're always working on the next
thing we just do a staring
contest that's what makes us
human
um all of these steps though with GPT
right is it or gbt 3 3.5 for our steps
towards AGI with each of them are you
looking for a benchmark are you looking
for this is what we want to get to yeah
so you know before we head to product we
were sort of looking at academic
benchmarks and how well these models
were doing on academic benchmarks and
you know open AI is known for betting on
scaling you know throwing a ton of
compute and data on this uh neural
networks and seeing how they get better
and better at predicting the next token
but it's not that we really care about
the prediction of the next token we care
about the tasks in the real world to
which this correlates to and so that's
actually what we started seeing once we
put out um research in the real world
and we we build Out product through the
API eventually through CH GPT as well
and so now we actually have real world
examples we can see how our customers do
in um specific domains how it moves the
needle for specific businesses um and of
course with gbd4 we saw that it did
really well in um exams like sat and
elsat and so on so it kind of goes to
our earlier point that we're you know
continually evolving our definition of
what it means for these models to be
more capable um but you know as we
increase the the capability Vector what
we really look for is reliability and
safety uh these are very interweaved and
it's very important to make systems that
of course are increasingly capable but
that you can truly rely on and they are
robust and that you can trust the output
of the system so we're kind of pushing
in uh both of these vectors at the same
time and um you know as we build the
next model the next set of Technologies
we're both betting continuing to bet on
scaling but we're also looking at you
know this other uh element of
multimodality um because because we want
these models to kind of perceive the
world in a similar way to how we do and
you know we P perceive the world not
just in text but images and sounds and
so on so we want to have robust
representations of the world um in in
these models will GPT 5 solve the
hallucination problem well I mean
actually maybe like let's see um we've
made a ton of progress on the
hallucination issue um with gbd4 but
we're still quite uh we're not where
where we need to be but you know we're
sort of on the right track and it's it's
unknown it's research it it could be
that um continuing in this path of
reinforcement learning with human
feedback we can get all the way to
really reliable outputs and we're also
adding other elements like retrieval and
search so you can um you have the
ability to to provide more factual
answers or to get more factual outputs
from the model so there's a combination
of technologies that we're putting
together to kind of reduce the
hallucination issue Sam I I'll ask you
about the data the training data
obviously there's there's been you know
maybe maybe some people in this audience
who may not be thrilled about some of
the data that you guys have used to
train some of your models not too far
from here in in Hollywood people have
not been thrilled of Publishers when
you're when you're considering now as
you're as you're walking through and
going to work towards this these next
models what are the conversations you're
having around the data so a few thoughts
in different directions here one we
obviously only want to use data that
people are excited about us using like
we
don't we we want the model of this new
world to to work for uh everyone and we
want to find ways to make people say
like you know what I see why this is
great I see why this is like going to be
a new it may be a new way that we think
about some of these issues around data
ownership and uh like how economic flows
work but we want to get to something
that everybody feels really excited
about but one of the challenges has been
people you know different kinds of data
owners have very different pictures so
we're just experimenting with a lot of
things we're doing Partnerships of
different shapes um and we think that
like with any new field we find
something that sort of just becomes a
new standard also
uh I think as these models get smarter
and more
capable we will need less training data
so I think there's this view right now
which is that we're just going to
like you know models are going to have
to like train on every word Humanity has
ever produced or whatever and I I
technically speaking I don't think
that's what's going to be the longterm
path here like we have exist proof with
humans that that's that's not the only
way to become intelligent um and so I
think the conversation gets a little bit
um LED astray by this because what what
really will matter in the future is like
particularly valuable data you know
people want people trust the Wall Street
Journal and they want to see content
from that and the Wall Street Journal
wants that too and we find new models to
make that work but I think the the
conversation about data and the shape of
all of this um uh because of the
technological progress we're making it's
about to it's about to shift well
Publishers like my mine who might be out
there somewhere they want money for that
data is the future of this entire race
about who can pay the most for the best
data um no that was sort of the point I
was trying to make I guess inelegantly
the but you still needs some you will
need some but the core like the thing
that is the thing that people really
like about a GPT model uh is not
fundamentally that it has that it knows
particular knowledge there's better ways
to find that it's that it has this laral
reasoning capacity and that's going to
get better and better but that's that's
really what this is going to be about
and then there will be ways that you can
set up all sorts of economic
arrangements as a user or as a company
making the model or whatever to say all
right now you know I I understand that
you would like me to go get this data
from The Wall Street Journal I can do
that but here's the deal that's in place
so there'll be things like that but but
the fundamental thing about these models
is not that they memorize a lot of data
so sort of like the model where also you
right now you've got being integrated it
goes out looks for some of that data and
can bring back some of the and that's
you know on the internet we decided
again back in the early days of the
internet there were a lot of
conversations about what the different
models could be and we all kind of
decided on you know here's the the core
framework and there's different pieces
in there of course and we're all gonna
have to figure that out for AI well
speaking of Bing you and SAA and Adella
your 10 billion dollar friends or
Frenemies friends yeah yeah I won't
pretend that it's like a perfect
relationship but nowhere near the fremy
category it's really good like we have
our
squabbles you know we get increasingly
as you guys are are releasing more and
more products that they they seem to
compete in some places
um I mean I think that that's that
there's something core about this
language interface that is a big deal
and so there's going to be a lot of
people doing things for that
and and then there's other places like
you know we offer a version of the API
they offer a version of the API but like
that just that's like a very friendly
thing and we all like we work it out so
that we all benefit and we're all happy
and and we just want like we jointly
want as much usage of our models uh of
our as as possible so we're super
aligned there
um but yeah it's like make sense friends
friends you guys text we do hang a lot
okay all right all right um Mera you you
over the last number of months have
started to roll out a lot more
personalization to the model right you
can put in custom instructions you get a
get the voice now and we're going to
bring out one of the bring down the
screen to hear one of these clips but I
wanted to play one of these
conversations I had with chat GPT just
yesterday
it's a slow
screen chbt responds quicker than this
that's really embarrassing yeah yeah
we're going to get that better though
yeah you're going to work on that we'll
get it faster but that I can't help you
with but we'll get Chach no I'm saying
Chachi BT is faster than this yeah but
and I'm saying that's like it's not
often that people say Chach BT is faster
than
x I've got a big interview with open AI
Executives and I'm nervous any
advice absolutely given your background
as a technology columnist you're well
equipped for this just be yourself do
your homework on open ai's latest
developments and Trust in your expertise
remember they'll likely appreciate
thoughtful and well researched questions
and hey everyone gets
nervous take a deep breath and rock
it am I rocking it definitely I'm
rocking it all right are we rocking it
up here
okay but what's so striking about that
first of all I want every that's that's
the voice of chat GPT they have one of
five yeah yeah that I mean that is the
voice it is it sounds so human it sounds
so natural it knows about me because
I've already put into custom
instructions I'm a tech journalist it
also knows I'm allergic to avocado it's
always putting that in there don't eat
avocado I'm like I'm not asking about
avocado we got some work to do is there
is is there a a future and this is what
you're maybe trying to build here where
we have deep relationships with this
type of
Bot it's going to be a significant
relationship right because you know
we're we're building these systems that
are going to be everywhere in at your
home in your educational environment in
your work environment and maybe you know
when you're having fun and so that's why
it's actually so important to get it
right and we have to be so careful about
how we design this interaction so that
ultimately it's you know elevating and
it's fun and it's um it it makes
productivity better and it enhances
creativity um and you know this is
ultimately where we're trying to go and
as we increase the capabilities of the
technology we also want to make sure
that you know on on the product side um
we feel in control of these these
systems in the sense that we can steer
them to do the things things that we
want them to do and the output is
reliable that's very important and of
course we want it to be personalized
right and as as it has more information
about your preferences the things you
like the things you do um and the
capabilities of the models increase and
other features like memory and so on it
has of course it will become more
personalized and that's that's a goal it
will become more useful and it's it's
going to become
uh more fun and more creative and it's
not just one system right like you can
have many such systems personalized for
specific domains and tasks that's a big
responsibility though and you guys will
be in sort of control of people's
friends maybe people's it gets to being
people's lovers how do you how do you
guys think about that
control first of all I think
there's we're not going to be the only
player here like there's going to be
many people so we have we have we get to
put like our nudge on the trajectory of
this technological development and we've
got some opinions uh but a we really
think that the decisions belong to sort
of Humanity Society as a whole whatever
you want to call it and B we will be one
of many actors building sophisticated
systems here so it's going to be a
society wide discussion it's and there's
going to be all the normal forces
there'll be competing products that
offer different things there will be
different kind of
like societal Embraces push backs
there'll be regulatory stuff it's going
to be like the same complicated mess
that any new technological birthing
process goes through and then we we
pretty soon we'll turn around and we'll
all feel like we had smart AI in our
lives forever and you know that's just
that's that's the way of progress and I
think that's awesome
um I personally have deep misgivings
about this vision of the future where
everyone is like super close to AI
friends and not like more so than human
friends or whatever I personally don't
want that uh I accept that other people
are going to want that um and you know
some people are going to build that and
if that's what the world wants and what
we decide makes sense we're going to get
that I I personally think that
personalization is great personality is
great but it's important that it's not
like
person and and at least that you know
when you're talking to Ai and when
you're not uh you know we named it chat
gbt and not it's a long story behind
that but we name it chat gbt and not a
person's name
very intentionally and we do a bunch of
subtle things in the way you use it to
like make it clear that you're not
talking to a person um and I I think
what's going to happen is that in the
same way that
people have a lot of relationships with
people they're going to keep doing that
and then there'll also be these like AIS
in the world but you kind of know
they're just a different
thing when you're Sam this is another
question for you what is the ideal
device that we interact with these on
and I'm wondering if you I hear you and
Johnny IV have been talking uh you bring
something to show
us um I think I think there is something
great to do but I don't know what it is
yet yeah must have some idea a lot of
ideas yeah I'm interested in this topic
I think it is possible I think most of
the current thinking out there in the
world is quite bad about what we can do
with this new technology in terms of a
new Computing platform and I do think
every sufficiently big new technology
uh enables some new Computing platform
um but lots of ideas but like in the
very nent stage so it doesn't I guess
the question for me is is there
something about a smartphone or earbuds
or a laptop or a speaker that doesn't
quite work right now yeah of course so
much smartphones are great like I have
no interest and trying to go compete
with a
smartphone like it's a phenomenal thing
uh at what it does but I think the way
what AI enables is so fundamentally new
um that it is possible to and maybe we
won't like you know maybe maybe just
like for a bunch of reasons doesn't
happen but I think it's like well worth
the effort of talking about or thinking
about you know what can we make now that
before before we had computers that
could think was uh or computers that
could understand whatever you want to
call it was not possible and if the
answer that is nothing it would be like
a little bit disappointing well it
sounds like it doesn't look like a
humanoid robot which is good
it's definitely
not I don't think that quite works okay
speaking of Hardware I making your own
chips you want an answer no um directed
here uh are we making our own chips we
are trying to figure out what it is
going to take to scale to to deliver at
the scale that we think the world will
demand um and at the model scale that we
think the the research can support um
that might not require any custom
Hardware um and we have like wonderful
Partnerships right now with people who
are doing amazing work um so the default
path would certainly be not to but I
wouldn't I like I would never rule it
out are there any good alternatives to
Nvidia out
there uh Nvidia certainly has something
amazing amazing uh but you know I think
like the magic of capitalism is doing
its thing and a lot of other people are
trying and we'll see where it all shakes
out well we had Renee hos here from
armene is great here you guys have been
talking we said Hello friends yeah oh
you said hello not as close as SAA
you're not you're not no not a okay got
it got it
um um this is the really hard-hitting
this is we're getting yeah we're getting
to the hard we're about to get to the
hard hitting so um my colleagues
recently reported you guys are are are
actually looking the valuation is 80 to
90 billion and that you're expected to
reach a billion in Revenue are you
raising money no well I mean always but
not like this minute not right now not
not right now there's a people here with
money all right let's
talk um we we will need huge amounts of
capital to complete our mission and we
have been extremely upfront about that
um there has got to be something more
interesting to talk about in our limited
time here together than our future
Capital raising plans but we will need a
lot more money we don't know exactly how
much we don't know exactly how it's
going to be structured what we're going
to do but
um you know it like
shouldn't come as a surprise because we
have said this all the way through like
it's just a tremendously expensive
Endeavor where which part of the
business though right now is growing the
most miror you can also jump in
definitely the product side yeah with
with the research team is very important
to have you know density of talent small
teams that innovate quickly the product
side you know we're doing a lot of
things we're trying to push great uses
of AI out there both on platform side
and first party and work with customers
so that's Del and and the revenue is
coming mostly from that
API the the revenue for the company
Revenue oh um I'd say both sides yeah
both sides both sides yeah so my my
subscription to chat gbt plus is we
appreciate that yeah yeah how many
people here actually are subscribers to
chat gbt Plus thank you all very much
okay can you guys make a family
plan this a serious question serious
because I'm spending on two we'll talk
about it yeah okay this is what we're
really here for tonight um moving now a
little bit into policy and and some of
the fears it's not like super cheap to
run if we had a way to like yeah say
like hey you know you can have this for
like we can give you like way more for
the 20 bucks or whatever we would like
to do that and as we make the models
more efficient we'll be able to offer
more but it's it's not for like lack of
us wanting more people to use it that we
don't do things like family a family
plan for like $35 for two people that
the kind well
hling you know well I gave you the
sweatshirt and you know there's there's
something we can do there how do we go
from the chatbot we just heard that told
me to rock it to one that I don't know
can rock the world and end the
world well I don't think we're going to
have like a chat bot that ends the world
but how do we go to this idea of we have
we've got simple chat Bots they're not
simple they're they're Advanced what you
guys are doing but how do we go from
that idea to this fear that is now
pervading
everywhere
if if we are right about the trajectory
things are going to stay on and if we
right about not only the kind of like
scaling of the gpts but new techniques
that we interested in that could help
generate new knowledge and someone with
access to a a system like this can say
like help me hack into this computer
system or help me design uh you know
like a new biological pathogen that's
much worse than Co or any number of
other things
it seems to us like it doesn't take much
imagination to think about scenarios
that deserve great caution and and again
we we we all come and do this because
we're so excited about the tremendous
upside and the the incredibly positive
impact and I think it would be like a
moral failing not to go pursue that for
Humanity but we've got to address and
this happens with like many other
Technologies we've got to address the
downsides that come along uh with this
and it doesn't mean you don't do it it
doesn't mean you just say like this AI
thing we're going to like you know we're
going to like go like full Dune and like
blow up you know have not have computers
or whatever um but it means that you
like are thoughtful about the risks you
try to measure what the capabilities are
and you try to build your own technology
in a way and that that mitigates those
risk and then when you say like hey
here's a new safety technique you make
that available to
others and as you guys are thinking
about
building in in in this direction what
are some of those specific safety risks
you're looking to put
in I mean like sim said you've got the
capabilities and then there is always a
downside whenever you have such immense
and great capability there's always a
downside so we've got a fierce task
ahead of us to figure out what are these
downsides discover understand them build
the toools to mitigate them and it's not
you know like a single fix you usually
have to intervene everywhere from the
data to the model to um the tools in the
product and of course policy and then
thinking about the entire Regulatory and
um um societal infrastructure that can
kind of keep up with this technologies
that we're building because ultimately
what we want is to slowly roll out allow
these capabilities in a way that Mak
sense and allow Society to adapt um
because you know the the progress is
incredibly rapid and we want to allow
for adaptation and for the whole
infrastructure that's needed for these
Technologies to actually be absorbed
productively to exist and be there so
you know when you think about what are
sort of the concrete safety um
uh measures along the way I would say
number one is actually rolling out the
technology um and slowly making contact
with reality understanding how it
affects um uh certain use cases and
industries and actually dealing with the
implications of that whether it's
regulatory copyright um you know
whatever the impact is actually
absorbing that and dealing with that and
moving on to more and more more
capabilities I don't think that building
the technology in a lab in a vacuum
without contact with the real world and
with the friction that you see with
reality is a good way to actually deploy
it safely and this might be where you're
going but it seems like right now you're
also policing yourself right you're
setting things better and Sam that's
where I was going to ask you I mean you
seem to spend more time in Washington
than Joe Biden's dogs right now and I'm
I think I've only been twice this year
really that's I think
so anyway um but what is it specifically
that you would rather the government and
our Regulators do versus you have to do
first I the point Mira was making I
think is is really important that that
it's very difficult to make a technology
safe in the lab um Society uses things
in different ways and adapts in
different ways and I think the more we
deploy AI the more AI is used in the
world the safer AI gets and the more we
kind of like collectively decide hey
here here's a thing that is not an
acceptable risk tolerance and this other
thing that people worried about that's
that's totally okay um and you know like
we see this with many other Technologies
airplanes have gotten unbelievably safe
um even though they didn't start that
way and it was uh it was like careful
thoughtful engineering and um
understanding why when something went
wrong it went wrong and how to address
it and you know the shared best practice
is there I think we're going to see in
all sorts of ways that the things that
we worry about with AI in theory don't
quite play out in practice
um just like a ton of talk right now
about deep fakes and you know the the
impact that's going to have on uh
Society in all these different
ways I think that's an example of where
we were thinking about the last
generation too much and AI will disrupt
Society in all of these ways but you
know we all kind of are like they're
like oh that's a deep fake or oh it
might be a deep fake or oh that picture
video or audio like we we learn quickly
but but maybe the real problem this is
like speculation this is hard to know in
advance is not the Deep fake ability but
the sort of customized one-on-one
persuasion and that's where the
influence happens it's not it's not like
the fake image it's the this thing has a
subtle ability these things have a
subtle ability to influence people and
then we learn that that's the problem
and we we adapt uh so in terms of what
we'd like to see from governments uh I
think we've been like very miscar ized
here we do think that International
regulation is going to be important for
the most powerful models nothing that
exists today nothing that'll exist next
year uh but as we get towards a real
super intelligence as we get towards a
system that is like more capable uh than
like any humans um I think it's very
reasonable to say we need to treat that
with like caution and uh and a
coordinated approach but like we think
what's happening with open source is
great we think startups need to be able
to train their own models and deploy
them into the world and a regulatory
response on that would be a disastrous
mistake for this country or others um so
the message we're trying to get across
is you got to embrace what's happening
here you got to like make sure that we
get the economic benefits and the
societal benefits of it but let's like
look forward at where this where we
believe this might go and let's not be
caught flat footed if that happens you
mentioned deep fakes and I I want to
talk about AI generated content that's
all over the internet now who do you
guys think is responsible or or should
be responsible for policing some of this
or not policing but detection of some of
this is this on the social media
companies is this on open Ai and all the
other AI companies we're definitely
responsible for the technologies that we
develop and put out there and uh you
know misinformation and that's that's
clearly a big issue as we create more
and more capable
models and we've been developing
Technologies to deal with um uh the
provence of an image or a text and
detect output but it's a bit complicated
because you know you want to give the
user sort of flexibility and they you
also don't want them to feel monitored
and so you have to consider the user and
you also have to consider people that
are impacted by the system that are not
users and so these are quite nuanced
issues that that require um a lot of
interaction and input from not just your
users of the product but also of society
more broadly and figuring out you know
also with Partners um that that bring on
this technology and integrate it what
are the best ways to to deal with these
issues because right now there's no way
or no tool from open AI at least that I
that I can put in an image or some of
the text and ask is this AI generated
correct for for image we have actually
technology that's uh really good almost
you know 99% reliable but we're still
testing it it's early and we want to be
sure that it's going to work and even
then it's not just a technology problem
it's information is such a nuance and
Broad problem so you still have to be
careful about how you roll it out where
you integrate it um but we're certainly
working on the research side and for for
image at least we have a very reliable
tool in in the early stages
yeah and say it's when might you release
this you said you you said you're you're
working on this right now is this
something you plan to release oh um yes
yes for both images and text for text
we're trying to figure out what actually
makes sense um for for images it's a bit
more straight straightforward problem um
but in either case we definitely test it
out because we don't have all the
answers right like we're building these
Technologies first we don't have all the
answers so often we will experiment we
will put out something we will get
feedback but we want to do it in a
controlled way right um and sometimes
we'll take it back and will make it
better and roll it out again I I'll also
add that I think this idea of
watermarking content is not something
that everybody has the same opinion
about what is good and what is bad
there's a lot of people who really don't
want their generated content watermarket
and that's understandable in many cases
uh also it's not it's not going to be
super robust to everything like maybe
you could do it for images maybe for
longer text maybe not for short text but
over time there will be systems that
don't put the watermarks in and also
there will be people who really
like you know this is like a tool and up
to the human user how you use the tool
and I don't like this is why we want to
engage in the conversation like we are
willing to sort of like follow the the
collective wishes of society on this
point
and I don't think it's a black and white
issue uh at least think people are still
evolving as they understand all the
different ways we're going to use these
tools they're still evolving in their
thoughts about what they're going to
want here also to Sim's earlier point
it's not you know um it's not just about
truthfulness right and what's what's
real and what's not real actually I
think in the world that we're going
towards marching towards the the bigger
risk is is really this individualized p
uh persuasion and and how to deal that
then that's going to be a very tricky
problem to deal with all right I
realized I have five minutes left and we
were going to do some audience questions
so we can get to one audience or two
audience questions I'm going to finish
one one one last thought here um I can
actually not see a thing out there so um
I will ask one last question then we'll
we'll hopefully have time for one or two
so 10 years you were here 10 years ago
what we we touched on this as we were
we're starting here but what is your
biggest fear about the future and what
is your biggest hope with this
technology I I think the future is going
to be be like amazingly great we
wouldn't come work so hard on this if we
didn't I I think this is going to be
like I think this is one of the most
significant inventions Humanity has yet
done um so I'm super excited to see all
play out I think like things can get so
much better for people than uh than they
are right now and I'm I feel very
hopeful about that we we covered a lot
of the fears it it like again we're
clearly dealing with something very
powerful that's going to impact all of
us in ways we we can't perfectly foresee
yet um but like what a time to be alive
and and get to witness this you're not
so fearful but I was going to actually
ask this but I'll ask it now do you have
a bunker
this is the hard this is this is better
than the audience question this is not
better than I'm going to let that clock
run I'm not going to pay attention that
but I as we're thinking about fears I
just I'm wondering what if you have a
bunker and what fear that you have that
you'd say no I have like structures but
I wouldn't say like a bunker structures
none of this is going to help if AGI
goes wrong this is It's a ridiculous
question to be honest okay good good
good Mera with your hope and fear I mean
the hope is definitely to push our
civilization ahead with augmenting um
our collective intelligence and the
fears we talked a lot about the fears
but you know we've got this opportunity
right now um and you've got Summers and
Winters in Ai and so on but you know
when we look back 10 years from now I
hope that we get this right and I think
there are many ways to to mess it up um
and we've seen that with many
Technologies so I hope we get it
right all right we've got time right
here hi um Pam Dyan preferably uh
sensory consumer products AI my question
has to do with the inflection point we
are where we are with respect to Ai and
AGI what is the inflection point how do
you define that moment where we go from
where we are now
to however you would choose to
Define what is
Agi I think
it's it's going to be much more
continuous than that we're just on this
beautiful exponential curve whenever
you're on a curve like that you look
forward it looks vertical you look back
it looks horizontal that's true at any
point on there so a year from now we'll
be in a dramatically more impressive
place than and a year ago we were in a
dramatically less impressive place
but it'll be hard to point people will
try and say oh it was alphago that did
it it was gpt3 that did it it was GPT 4
that did it but it's just Brick by Brick
One Foot In Front of the other up
climbing this exponential
curve right here in the
front thank you my name is noriana micho
I'm the Chief Information officer at the
Port of Long Beach but I'm also computer
Scientist by training a few decades ago
I'm older than you I remember working
with some the early AI people I have a
general question I agree with you this
is one of the most significant
Innovations to
happen one of the things I've struggled
with over the last 20 years and thinking
about this we're about to change the
nature of work this is that significant
and I feel the people are not talking
about it there will be a significant
there'll be a transition time period
where significant population in the
world and in this country will not have
had the types of discussion understand
that we have so they can like you
mentioned Society needs to be a part of
it there's a large portion of society
that's not even in this discussion so
the nature of work will change it used
to be that things that were just um
going to be automated there will be a
time where people who Define themselves
by work since thousands of years will
not have that and we're hurling towards
it what can we do to make sure that we
take that into account cuz when we talk
about Society it's not like they all
together ready to discuss this some of
the effects of some of the technologies
that we brought into the world have
actually made people separate from each
other how do we get some of those not
regulations but how do we come up with
some of those Frameworks and voluntarily
bring things about that will actually
result in a better world that doesn't
leave everybody else behind thank
you
okay I I'll give you my perspective I I
think I completely agree with you that
it's one of it's the ultimate technology
that could really increase inequality
and make make things so much worse for
us as human beings and civilization or
it could be you know really amazing and
it could bring along a lot of creativity
and productivity and enhance us and you
know maybe a lot of people don't want to
work um 8 hours or 100 hours a week
maybe they want to work four hours a day
and do a bunch of other things and you
know um I I think it's certainly going
to lead to a lot of disruption in the
workforce and we don't know exactly the
scale of that um or or the trajectory
along the way but that's that's for sure
and one of the things that um I in
retrospect it's not that we specifically
planned it but in retrospect I'm happy
about is that with the release of chbt
we sort of brought AI into the
um you know Collective Consciousness and
people are kind of paying attention
because they're not reading about it in
the Press um people are not just telling
them about it but they can play with it
they can interact with it and get a
sense for the capabilities and so I
think it's actually really important to
bring these Technologies into the world
and make them as widely accessible as
possible um you know Sam mentioned
earlier like we're working really hard
to make these models cheaper and faster
so they're accessible very broadly but I
think that's key for people themselves
to actually interact with the technology
and experience it um and sort of
visualize how it might change their way
of life their way of being and
participate uh as you know uh as as in
providing uh product feedback but also
you know institutions need to actually
prepare for these changes in the
workforce and economy
Sam I'll give you the last yes
absolutely I I think it's a super
important question um every
technological Revolution affects the job
market uh and over human history you
know every maybe 100 years you can feel
different numbers for this 150 years
half the kind of jobs go away totally
change whatever um I'm not afraid of
that at all in fact I think that's good
I think that's the way of progress and
we'll find new and better jobs the thing
that I think we do need to confront as a
society is the speed at which this is
going to happen it seems like over you
know two maximum three probably two
generations we can adapt Society can
adapt to almost any amount of of job
market change but a lot of people like
their jobs or they dislike change and
going to someone and saying hey the
future will be better I promise you and
society's going to win but you're going
to lose here that that doesn't work
that's not a that's not cool like that's
that's not a nice that's not an easy
message to get across
and Al although I tremendously believe
that we're not knocking around on things
to do people that want to work less fine
they'll be able to work less but you
know probably many people here don't
need to keep working and and we all do
like we we there's like great
satisfaction in expressing yourselves in
in being useful and sort of contributing
back to society that's not going away um
that that is such an innate human desire
like Evolution doesn't work that fast uh
also the sort of ability to creatively
express yourself and to sort of leave
something to to to add something back to
the trajectory of the species is that
that's that's like a wonderful part of
The Human Experience so we're going to
keep finding things to do and the people
in the future will probably think some
of the things we we think some of the
things those people do very silly and
not real work in a way that like a
hunter gatherer probably wouldn't think
this is real work either you know we're
just trying to like entertain ourselves
with some silly status game that's fine
with me that's how it goes um
the but we are going to have to really
do something about this transition is it
is not enough to just give people a
universal basic income people need to
have agency the ability to influence
this they need we need to sort of
jointly be architects of the future and
one of the reasons that we feel so
strongly about deploying this technology
as we do as you said not everybody's in
these discussions but more and more are
every year and by putting this out in
people's hands and making this super
widely available and getting billions of
people to use chat gbt not only do
people have the opportunity to think
about what's coming and participate in
that conversation um but people use the
tool to push the future forward um and
that's really important to
us